yeah so because you're you are one of
the few La artists who can like kind of
navigate around like a bunch of
different pockets of the scene out here
like sure like I'll see you doing a
record like Swifty blue and it's like
not out of the blue and then you could
work with you know I mean you're
obviously a [ __ ] so there's that you
know what I mean so yeah
um yeah I feel like you might be the
only guy that's kind of like in that
lane and kind of just Diversified I
could go anywhere yeah yeah I feel you
is that fair do you feel that way I love
that that's amazing I [ __ ] with that I
don't want to just be in a pocket or in
a boxing shirt that's fair you know what
I'm saying yeah you've I feel like since
the first time I met you I remember uh I
want to say Nema told me about you like
maybe a year and a half ago or so when
you first signed right
um you've just been working man going in
Non-Stop going in how many projects have
you dropped in the last like two years
oh I want to say maybe
13. [ __ ]
13 projects in the last two years you
know I got some [ __ ] I got a rock
project I'm working on it's just you got
to just keep flooding you never know
what what pocket everybody's gonna
really appreciate and I love everything
yeah and like your fan bases like you
see the the growth man yeah what do you
think because like I feel like
you know there's a lot of people who can
make great music but it's kind of hard
to like convert those into like fans or
people who people might follow you but
like how do you get them to spend money
with you how do you get them to like
really buy into what you're doing to
where you're not just having followers
you have people who actually support you
for one you have to be a communicator
and you have to be somebody that speaks
you have to be somebody that people can
mesh well with see it's easy for me to
like maybe come up to this podcast show
say I had like a link up in my head
right a bunch of face tats and my
attitude and my personality was terrible
right right they have fans for that but
then when you really like sit down with
yourself and you discuss who you are and
you do these interviews like the bootleg
cab podcast you go and do this [ __ ]
hot 97 [ __ ] you do whatever no jumper
they get to really know who you are and
they fall in love with you you know what
I'm saying you just keep it real and
authentic that's how I feel like I've
got my cult following I mean I got
people that got my face tatted
everywhere you know I feel like not just
based on my music but based on my
character and who I am and how I'm so
relatable and I'm not a fake ass [ __ ]
wow yes how many people have do you have
like a count like uh how many people
have your face tattooed on their body I
would say
maybe like from what I know about like
13 people wow portraits that's funny
male and female melon it's just you know
what I'm saying it's just impressive
dude yeah yeah no I feel like it's
pretty dope it's cool I was kind of
surprised when I started first seeing
them yeah when you saw the first one did
it like freak you out a little or was it
like I said no way and I started
refreshing the page I'm like what no
[ __ ] way bro and then I started
refreshing it some more I was like no
hell no and I was like okay this is
really lit and then after the fourth
fifth one it's like okay cool dope
thanks for joining the team [ __ ] so
someone gets the face tattoo do they
just get like free concert tickets or I
embrace them for sure like anybody or is
it also they might be like a little
crazy no I'm not you never know man I
don't know uh I feel like no I embrace
them just as much as I do anybody else
bro you know what I'm saying listen if
someone gets a bootleg cab face tattoo
I'm I might block them and run because
I'm an ugly [ __ ] man
that's a questionable human being yeah
what the [ __ ] I mean you you know you're
you're you've got great music I just
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] for a living so yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no good looking out
bro no yeah I mean honestly I just
embrace them like anybody else what's
been the like most craziest spot they've
got in the tattoo
maybe like right above like like a girl
getting it like right above like right
here really that's about as crazy as it
got there's a girl who's got your face
over her vagina like kinda like yeah not
something yeah but yes so when she wears
a bikini your face is right she has some
you know she's summertime she going out
there you know what I'm saying how does
your lady feel about that I feel like in
the beginning she was weirded out like
what like she kind of got a little
weirded out and irritated but does she
have your face tattooed on her she has
my name okay but not your face not my
face
this [ __ ] got your face on what is
going on
nah she has my she has my name but no no
face though
yeah did you meet that girl have you met
her in person yeah I met pretty much all
of them I met like
nine of them the other ones I haven't
met in person wow